at this point in your life who is teresa
giudice I'm standing strong I am Who I
am and you know I'm confident Teresa
Giudice has a whole new attitude after
her trip to see her estranged husband
Joe in Italy where he's currently
awaiting a final decision on his appeal
to being deported
how was the reunion with Joe in Italy
anyways amazing anyways yeah it was
great
a lot of happy tears it was just like I
was so overwhelmed seeing how happy my
daughters were I'm happy Joe was I was
like I was like over the moon just it
was just it was just great to see them
reunite yeah you know after all this
time I mean because you hadn't seen him
basically in nearly four years because
he's been serving jail time for I'm
gonna have seen him like I would see him
you know at the imprison right and at
the one place we were able to see each
other face to face but then when he went
to ice he was behind a glass so and that
was terrible but so you were you were
able to see one another freely with it
wasn't any sort of like confinement
totally free that's it like you know him
now he bet he's in Italy he's you know
he's not on probation nothing he's free
as can be why are you crying now we've
been through a lot and I'm just happy
he's free you said in that interview
with Andi that you had to see each other
to know where your relationship was
standing and how you would move forward
so where are things now well this trip
to Italy was all about the kids it was
all about the kids you know being
together with their bed and and just Joe
and I being in a good place which we
were and we'll just take him day by day
and see you know we're gonna see what
happens so you know we both want each
other to be happy which that's the most
important thing and our both common
denominator is our four daughters like
we just want and of course we're gonna
do what it takes to you know for the
happiness of our daughters so that's
that's that's our goal like as long as
they're happy we're happy it seems to me
that you and Joe you want to make sure
that you're setting your daughters up
for success and their happiness but that
the two of you are seemingly done do you
feel like you are gonna sever ties and
part ways completely I mean we haven't
decided yet Joe lives it out you know
eight hour plane ride in Italy you know
I live in America I don't know if that's
gonna work how do you hope your life
looks in five 10 years
I'll never answer that question when I
started the show like okay I I got asked
that question all the time and I
answered it I never saw myself in prison
ever so like now I'll never answer that
question ever again like I'll have like
you know I guess goals in my head but I
never want to you know like it I'll put
them out in the universe for myself but
I don't want to just voice him out to
just the world just because that's how I
feel now just because of what happened
to me is one of your hopes maybe to be
happily married and reunited with Joe
one of my hopes is to be happy and in
love and to live happily ever after yes
with or without you
exactly for both of us and I'm always
gonna love Joe he's always gonna love me
we're always gonna be a family our goal
is to focus always on our four daughters
you
[Music]